- And also, you're not supposed
to have a girlfriend until you're 35.
(energetic music)
- She is loving, but very strict.
- She's constantly moving,
constantly working,
constantly offering you food.
- I would say my mom is wild.
She's very energetic and very silly.
- She can yell.
Like, across a football stadium.
"Sissy Joanne!"
- What have I done in my past life
to deserve this? (chuckles)
- She'd be like, "Huh?"
- "Huh? What did you say?
"Can you say that again?
"Say that to your mother."
- I always just figured I would never date
when I was in high school,
or that if I was gonna do it, I'd have
to do it in secret behind her back.
- They want you to focus on schoolwork,
and then by 25, they're like,
"What's wrong with you?" (chuckles)
- "Kevin, if you had a girlfriend,
"you would tell me, right?"
I'm just like, "Yeah, sure."
- "You don't need any
other man in your life
"besides your father."
- Discussions with my mom about dating
were basically nonexistent.
- When I go shopping
with her, she'll be like,
"Nothing past $10."
- My mom has basically taught me
that I don't have to pay
anything at full price.
- "You have a shirt just like that, Sissy.
"Why would you spend any more money
"on another shirt like that?"
- "Kevin, you need to
think about the family.
"It's not just about you."
- Up until college, I wore exclusively
JCPenney clothes.
- With career, my mom
was just always like,
"Are you sure you don't
want to be a nurse?"
- "Well, you studied something Englishy.
"You could go to law school."
- When my mom met my roommate,
who is a programmer, she was like,
"Chris could have been a programmer too.
"He majored in programming, but you know,
he's not a programmer." (chuckles)
- "You know, you should
get your master's degree.
"Oh, you know, there's still time
"to be a pharmacist."
- "Doctor" still gets thrown around.
- "Oh, why don't you become a doctor?"
- She wanted me to grow in her footsteps
and do that same career, but it never
really worked out, and I think
she just got over it after a while.
- Sometimes moms just have a hard time
accepting the fact that
they can't help you
with everything.
I think that's also a
really good opportunity
for you to bond with each other.
- I'd resented it when I was younger,
but I appreciate it now, and
I wouldn't change anything.
- And so I don't think
I could ever thank her
enough for just always looking out for me
and making sure that
had my head on straight,
had money in my pocket,
and my stomach was full.
(energetic music)